ta augmenté de +2 69% au cours des neuf
premiers mois de l'année 2018
d'où cette question qui revient à ce que
nous sommes en train de revivre une
période sombre de l'histoire de l'europe
celle des années 30 c'est en tout cas la
conviction des manuels macron il leur
disait encore mardi dernier dans un
entretien à nos confrères d'europe 1 et
moi je suis frappé de voir deux choses
qui ressemblent terriblement aux années
le fait que notre europe a été bousculé
par une crise économique et financière
profonde qui a plongé des pays dans des
crises extrêmement dur sur le plan
social vous connaissez bien la grèce da
grèce le portugal et nous voyons à
nouveau une montée des nationalismes qui
joue sur ses potes qui ont bernard allez
allez allez juste cette analogie
alors écoutez j'aurais envie de vous
dire ce qu'a dit zemmour ce cas la
question que zemmour a posé en disant
mais alors dans ce cas là quel rôle joue
t'il si nous sommes dans les années 30
c'est daladier c'est camille chautemps
quel rôle joue notre ami macron s'était
pas tout à fait ma question je sais bien
sûr non sincèrement est-ce qu'il est
juste que non je ne je ne pense pas je
pense que les l'histoire ne repasse pas
les plats que l'on à des circonstances
qui sont parfaitement comment dire
différentes et que le fait de vouloir
assimiler
je dirais des périodes
ainsi ne a pour but est évidemment de
créer une situation mais ni kent où il y
aurait les gentils et les méchants
sous-entendu ceux qui sont dans le fond
aujourd'hui susceptibles de contester la
construction européenne telle qu'elle se
fait de discuter je dirais des flux
migratoires de mettre en avant une
insécurité culturelle et morale dans le
corps social ne serait finalement que
des gens qui adorent et adopté
l'idéologie nazie
sincèrement ce n'est pas sérieux ce
n'est pas sérieux
quant à la question de l'antisémitisme
plus précisément je crois que là aussi
on fait semblant de croire que les
causes je dirais qu ayant mené à ces
actes antisémites seraient les mêmes
aujourd'hui que dans les années 30
personne n'ose y est alors que enfin si
quand même ça donne aux personnes qui le
disent que incontestablement l'origine
actuel de l'antisémitisme et des actes
antisémites
c'est essentiellement c'était
essentiellement ressort islamistes et
donc par conséquent je crois que vouloir
faire cette comparaison me paraît
malsain
tu es de finale comparaison n'est jamais
raison ça pour le coup et je trouve ça
toujours être chromatique voire absurde
de comparer des périodes historiques
ça n'a jamais tout à fait nages m ces
deux n est l'acronyme exactement essais
et c'est tout à fait faux et là les
points de ressemblance peuvent tourner
virer vite à l'indécence je trouve quand
on peut quand on compare mêlant le
mouvement de mélenchon mouvement de
marine le pen
ad
idéologie totalitaire comme le
stalinisme nazisme c'est presque
indécent pour ceux qui ont véritablement
souffert de ces totalitarisme là mais ça
explique quoi en fait la généalogie de
ça s'est vraiment joué sur l'idéologie
de la peur on a quand même peur d'à peu
près tout dans notre société actuelle
alors que ça ne justifie pas forcément
et jouer instrumentaliser la peur des
gens et jouer sur les émotions c'est
vraiment de la politique émotionnelle
mais pas du tout rationnel et je trouve
ça et je trouve que cette ces fausses
ressemblance tourne vraiment à
l'indécence de régulièrement peut-être
gérard wey plusieurs choses monde jette
sur le l'antisémitisme bon alors moi
j'ai été regardé les chiffres de
l'antisémitisme sur le long terme
en réalité c'est une courbe sinusoïdale
c'est à dire que ça baisse
où ça descend de 50% à peu près tous les
ans donc séparé en baisse depuis deux
ans absolument donc au jour cette année
ça augmente de 60 9%
c'est pas une tendance sur plusieurs
années donc on peut pas en tirer une
conclusion sur plusieurs années première
chose mon deuxième chose je suis
d'accord avec tout ce qui a été dit
cette comparaison avec les années 30
elle a surtout un intérêt politique qui
est de faire peur et d'apparaître
électoralement comme un rempart à la
barbarie qui ferait représenter par les
nationalistes nouveau navy ça veut pas
dire que faut pas s'inquiéter de la
montée des nationalismes
mais c'est qu'il est beaucoup trop pv de
juste expliquer qu'on est dans un climat
après années 30 et donc qu'il faut voter
c'est là que la fameuse couverture de
libération avant le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle faites ce que vous voulez
mais votez macron voilà en réalité le
message sous tendu c'est celui là
très intéressant que le débat politique
puisse aller un peu plus loin sur les
idées par exemple je vous donne des
points de vue de d'internautes
christophe qui nous dit comparaison
n'est pas raison l'antisémitisme de 2018
n'est pas celui des années 30
un autre internaute nous dit ce chiffre
ne vient-il pas du fait que ces actes
sont plus répertoriés et que les actes
d'agression dans leur ensemble donc pas
seulement les actes antisémites augmente
et w 2010
une stratégie pour les élections
européennes et tania nous dit pourquoi
regarder seulement les chiffres sur deux
ans quelle évolution sur 10 ou 20 ans on
a comme on a essayé de vous répondre à
l'instant tania et pour une chose nous
dit le problème c'est de prendre un
critère est d'en faire une généralité
on n'est pas vraiment dans les années 30
n'en trouve pas grand monde pour
l'instant pour défendre le point de vue
du président est-ce que vous c'est ça va
être votre cas daniel bilalian je suis
d'accord il s'y était dit c'est-à-dire
comparer la situation actuelle aux
années 30 et dire d'une certaine façon
il ya une nationalisme ou le populisme
serait une montée de l'antisémitisme
c'est sous-entendu ça me paraît un tout
petit peu bizarre et aujourd'hui en
france par exemple les 11 millions de
français qui ont voté marine le pen ne
sont pas des antisémites ça ça remonte
aux camarades de son père mais en tout
cas ce sont des gens qui se plaignent de
leur nom de leur vie et de la
mondialisation etc
donc je trouve trouve très dangereux de
laisser à penser que c'est que c'est ça
mais c'est sa grande son grand combat
laurent wauquiez l'a dit l'autre jour le
président république et cynique il dit
c'est moi ou le nationalisme
ils essayent de supprimer ce qui était
la droite le rpr et l'udf et c'est donc
c'est très intelligent de sa part et en
même temps très cynique c'était c'est
moi ou le nationalisme c'est moi ou
l'antisémitisme sous entendu je trouve
ça un petit peu fort de café
et en plus je pense que honnêtement
français moyen ne fait pas de référence
à ça et qu'on joue là il comprend pas
comprend pas ce qu'on lui dit il
comprend pas à ce point 0,10 et ne fait
que favoriser parce que c'est quand on
aime on dit à un homme mais ta femme est
abominable l'affreuse banane n'y a rien
de mieux pour la valoriser il valait
trouvait pas si mal que ça qu'est ce que
je veux c'est exactement ce que je
reproche mois alors ça c'est au produit
ce matin lorsqu'il fait cette
intervention sur facebook c'est toujours
le politiquement correct on dit pas d'où
viendrait l'antisémitisme d'aujourd'hui
mais on sait que l'antisémitisme vient
principalement de l'islam radical
mais ça on ne le dit pas on ne dit rien
on dit rien au cas où
au cas où donc là encore le français
moyen lui dit voilà il ose pas dire que
l'islam radical
c'est le
fournisseur essentiel les principales de
l'antisémitisme seulement la déclaration
de moi je ne sais pas comment un premier
ministre dire voilà il y a il se passe
quelque chose et ne pas dire d'où ça
vient ces scènes de violence on sait
bien que pour parler de la délinquance
ond parler des jeunes
alors elle sait très bien qui est
proposé avec conditions qui ont conduit
ce plutôt certains c'est un an
volontairement mais qui les conduisent
plutôt à du verre est anticipée à cela à
ces actes délictueux et donc par
conséquent évidemment il y à un risque
pour le coup évidemment de ce que cette
dénonciation fort légitime puisse se
retourner contre ceux qui évidemment
cherche à exploiter politiquement
et puis il ya aussi un autre élément
c'est que s'il y a je dirais des actes
contre je dirais certaines catégories de
la population ne faut pas oublier qu'il
y a des profanations d'églises des
profanations de cimetières chrétiens qui
sont là aussi pour le coup plutôt en
augmentation alors ça n'est sans doute
pas que le fait je dirais de du
multiculturalisme et de la présence du
der et d'un islam conquérant en france
il ya aussi évidemment toutes les sectes
sataniques etc
mais il est incontestable que ne pas
nommer je dirais les causes ou du moins
certaines causes susceptibles d'être à
l'origine d'un phénomène
eh bien ça ne me paraît pas très
respectueux ni de ceux à qui on
s'adresse ni efficace pour pouvoir gérer
la question vous pose la question sur
twitter un est ce que cette comparaison
est pertinente quand on parle de la
montée de l'antisémitisme et du
populisme
vous considérez majoritairement que non
à 76 % ont plus demandés ginger si le
pression la république lui-même n'est
pas en train de revenir un petit peu sur
7 sur cet argument un peu un peu simple
ou un peu un peu binaire
dans la même interview à europe 1 il
expliquait que l'europe
était ultra libérale que elle ne
permettait plus aux classes moyennes de
vivre correctement arguments qu'on
entendait classiquement plutôt chez ce
que emmanuel macron appelé jusque là les
populistes
il essaye de jouer sur tous les tableaux
mais en réalité cet argument là on
l'entend d'à peu près tous les partis
avant les élections européennes
on a rare on entend rarement des partis
se satisfaire de la bonne marche et du
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes avant les élections c'est la
figure imposée d'expliquer que l'idée
européenne est une superbe idée mais que
oui il ya des ça fonctionne pas très
bien et qu'on va le faire beaucoup mieux
fonctionner et où des abus et on va
faire book fair ça beaucoup mieux
fonctionner dans les années à venir
un bon est-ce qu'il est crédible sur
cette thématique là pas forcément parce
que tous ces actes depuis qu'il a été
élu vont dans le sens de ce que font les
européistes que fait la commission
européenne à l'échelle de l'union
pardon à les dénombrer mais puis la
dénonciation du nationalisme encore
faut-il s'entendre sur ce qui est
dénoncé
parce que quand on fait l'histoire du
mot je vous renvoie notamment aux
travaux de jean pierre des scot sur
cette question le nationalisme ça peut
être un nationalisme impérialistes c'est
effectivement le sens qu'il a lorsque
valmy vive la nation la révolution
française qui veut porter les idéaux au
delà des frontières
mais ça peut être aussi le nationalisme
de réaction c'est à dire le nationaliste
de protection lorsque et bien il ya
l'agression allemande en 1870 lorsque il
y a généré 1
comment dire une forme de de
désorganisation du corps social par 9e
comment dire par parler ces situations
la situation fait je dirais aux
catégories les plus populaires donc le
nationalisme tel qu'il peut apparaître à
la fin des années à la fin du 19e siècle
il peut avoir deux facettes
la facette du nationalisme
révolutionnaire ou la facette du
nationalisme de réaction est plutôt
protectionnistes donc ccc encore faut-il
de quoi savoir de quoi l'on parle
et mettre dans le même sac je dirais les
différentes sensibilités que ce même
terme qui est polysémique peut recouvrir
sa me parait idéologiquement
effectivement discutable
oui j'allais aller exactement dans le
même sens ce sens le problème c'est le
problème des mots c'est à dire que on
édulcore et on adoucit tout le langage
pour ne pas signifier les vraies causes
et les vrais dangers
donc les mots on a peur que le mot
chiens mordent à la limite c'est
vraiment le problème du nominalisme et
de l'autre côté on sort des grands mots
des gros mots capitalisme libéralisme
comme si c'était des boucs émissaires et
des explications de tous c'est vraiment
un problème de langage à un moment il
faut parler avec des mots vrais et je
pense pour revenir sur la colère des
gens dans les provinces c'est ça aussi
dont ils ont marre un peu de ces de ces
poncifs
ils ont envie de se confronter à la
réalité et notamment à la réalité des
mots polis encore est qu'il ya aussi des
mots très durs prenante lorsqu'il parle
des populistes de la lèpre populiste et
moi c'est ce mot populiste à partir de
vent ou les parties deviennent
majoritaires dans leur pays devienne
populaire à partir vous avez la majorité
vous n'êtes plus populiste au sens
négatif du titre vous êtes populaire
qu'est ce que cette façon de parler
c'est le résultat du vote démocratique
alors on peut le regretter mais c'est
ainsi
cette émission est importante d'abord
parce qu'on est dit plein de choses
passionnantes et en plus que ce que nous
allons essayer